- Our next review is from
Joaquin Phoenix.
- Oh, you're kidding me!
- Oh, wow!
- Oh!
Oh.
- Hi, I'm Joaquin in Phoenix.
I have to apologize to everyone
at my church this Sunday.
What's it like to speak
in public?
- Oh, well, I guess this is
exactly the moment to confess
that even though I'm a seasoned
and very highly well regarded
television presenter,
I occasionally feel
the terror of stage fright.
- Sometimes I can see
the sweat building
on your upper lip
from over here.
- No, no, for me it's more
of an internal thing.
I don't think it's noticeable.
Okay, well, I am off
to speak publicly!
I have recently learned that my
ex-wife is getting married
to a man that I accidentally
introduced her to.
Suzanne met this man
during my review of catfishing
when I used his annoyingly
perfect face
to communicate with her.
When she wanted to meet me,
I kept up the ruse,
and produced Joe Dale, Jr.,
who, as it turns out,
is a wealthy
professional athlete.
- Hello.
- Soon after,
they started dating.
So he is a fraud,
and she is a dupe.
And not only that,
he cheats on her...all the time.
So, if that doesn't have
the makings
of a memorable wedding speech,
I don't know what does.
I set to work writing a speech
to deliver
at their rehearsal dinner,
one that would completely
derail this wedding of lies.
"Are marrying a stand-in
for the man you really
fell for."
The speech I have written
is a vicious, destructive act
of character assassination.
But that doesn't make it immune
from the number one rule
of public speaking:
I gotta open with a joke.
Now, I remember that my late
father-in-law Jack
opened his toast at our wedding
with a real doozey.
So I've been combing through
the home video of our wedding.
I think I've got it.
Let's see that joke.
- Oh, but I think Forrest
is a little nervous.
Today he asked me
what the wedding night
was gonna be like, and I said,
oh, don't worry,
it's like a candy bar...
- Oh, no, no, don't tell--
- Dad! Dad!
- It's like a candy bar.
Once you take the wrapper off,
the next two minutes
will be heavenly.
[laughter]
Love that joke!
Seriously though,
I love this guy.
He's a little weird sometimes.
I don't always know what he's
talking about, but darn it,
he--he makes my daughter happy,
and that's all
a dad can ask for his kids.
So, Forrest, I want you to
promise that you'll always
keep my little girl happy.
Can you promise me that?
- Yes, I promise.
- Say it again.
- I promise.
- One more time.
- Thank you.
May you two have many children,
who will likely be the first
generation to live in space.
So with that in mind,
let's toast.